let's talk about the best herbs for
parasites
now what is a parasite a parasite could
be some microorganism
a worm a bacteria that basically
lives off your body but doesn't give you
anything
back at least your friendly bacteria
exchange with you
they give you immune protection they
help make
vitamins vitamin k k2
a whole series of b vitamins they
actually make
antioxidants they'll even eat things
that you don't even eat
they'll eat fiber and they convert it
into things like
chemicals like butyrate which help give
your colon cells
energy and they even help with your
blood sugars
let me give you another example of what
i consider a parasite
one day i saw this flyer of
this guy who's will come your house and
cut your grass
call them up say he's going to cut my
grass
so i left i had to go somewhere i come
back
he broke into my house and he stole
things
and not only that he didn't even cut my
grass
so that would be an example of someone
taking something
but not giving anything back all right
so let's talk about
some of the symptoms that might occur if
someone has parasites all right number
one
fatigue that's a real big symptom weight
loss
itchy private parts bloating
your nauseous diarrhea
now what are the best remedies for
parasites
wormwood extract you can get this at the
health of the store
it's a very very toxic plant for
parasites because the goal
is to make the environment so unfriendly
that the parasites have to leave your
body number two black walnut halls
very very toxic to parasites
garlic has been known to even kill
parasites
and clove okay this is the combination
that i would recommend
now of course when you are trying to get
rid of parasites
you want to avoid certain foods
especially sugary foods
refined carbohydrates and definitely
milk
now before you start these herbs
i'm going to recommend you get some
purified bile salts
and you want to take i'd say
maybe three through the day on an empty
stomach
so maybe you take one in the morning one
in the early afternoon and then maybe
one before you go to bed
okay so do that for one day then the
second day you start on this protocol
why because when you take purified bile
salts
you will start to open up the flows of
your bile ducts
and because when you start to take these
herbs
it's going to kill off microbes it can
even break open
the microbe which could actually release
endotoxins
which tend to shut down the bile ducts
and that's when you feel sick when
you're trying to do a detox or you're
trying to
kill off parasites or fungus so i always
recommend this
take this one little step get your liver
and bile ducts flowing first for a day
then do this i've learned the hard way
i've done so many different cleanses and
even parasite
cleanses and i end up getting sick
because i didn't know about this
you keep those bile ducts open and keep
things flowing
and you won't have any detox reactions
so
when you take these as well go slow like
maybe take one of each
see how you do and then the next day
take a little bit more
a little bit more until you reach the
recommended amount on the directions
that is on the bottle now when you're
doing parasite cleanses i would do them
for
minimally one month but maybe six weeks
and then at that point stop taking it
see how you do and it's not a bad thing
to do this
every so often maybe every six months
and one last thing that i think is
really really important is taking
apple cider vinegar on a regular basis
you can even give apple cider vinegar to
animals to kill off their parasites
so this is a really good thing for
humans as well
all right thanks for watching hey before
you go real quick
i have a course entitled how to
bulletproof
your immune system it's a free course i
want you to take it
and here's why here's you
here is your environment
everyone is focused on this over here
avoiding your environment but what about
here
what about strengthening your immune
system
that's what's missing this course will
show you how to bulletproof yourself
and so you can tolerate and resist your
environment much better
by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description
right down below
check it out and get signed up today